[Music]
straight ahead
online crime daily christian paneja
rivera found guilty of murdering college
student
molly tibbetts we just spoke to the
family they're relieved they're
pleased with the verdict could lori
valodebel face charges for another death
after she was indicted for the murders
of her two children
investigators are the doomsday mom
crossing state lines bill cosby
remaining behind bars
after a parole board denies his release
the actor maintaining his innocence as
the board says
he failed to complete sex offender
programs james procopovich is sentenced
for the murder and disappearance of his
wife
the victim's daughter pleading to know
where her mother's body is
tell us where she is law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the verdict is in for an iowa farm
worker accused of murdering a college
student and leaving her body in a
cornfield
let's get straight to it we the jury
find the defendant christian bahina
rivera
guilty of the crime of murder in the
first degree
that's guilty of the first degree murder
of molly tibbetts our aunt jeannette
levy has been
following this case closely and is here
to break down how the jury reached its
verdict
yeah brian five women and seven men
ranging in age from
19 to 71 sat on that jury three were
latino
and nine were white they heard days of
testimony and they even heard from the
defendant himself
molly is no longer on this planet
because of the defendant
the state says christian bahina rivera
is a murderer
why would this happen
because he's angry because he wants to
have some sort of relationship with her
because he finds her hot or attractive
but bahina rivera took the stand
and told another story contradicting his
own statement to investigators that he
approached mollie tibbetts because he
thought she was hot
and she slapped him and threatened to
call police he told jurors he placed her
body in the cornfield
after being abducted by two masked men
who killed her
and put her in his trunk which explains
tibbetts blood being there
did you cover her with corn
because i didn't want to leave her well
i didn't want her to be too exposed to
the sun
the defense suggested mollie tibbetts
boyfriend dalton jack had the motive to
kill her
and investigators didn't investigate
other possible suspects
what happened here was they closed the
case
they didn't solve a case bahina rivera's
attorney says the state's story
simply doesn't make sense the concept
that he got angry and
killed a woman who he had just met
defies any logic
now after the verdict was read the
prosecutors who tried the case
spoke about how they're feeling about
the verdict and about molly tibbetts
family uh we feel great i mean this was
the
verdict that we wanted it was the
verdict that the evidence
demanded and uh great for all parties
that justice was served
they're relieved they're pleased with
the verdict
it's just they're you know the whole the
family of molly tibbets is just a great
bunch
and they've been awesome to to work with
in this circumstance of course it's
always very tragic
uh and uh whenever something like this
happens
uh to to a family like them or any
family and
christian bahayna rivera's defense
attorneys also spoke
following the verdict and they said that
they're of course disappointed by it but
they said they appreciated the time that
the jury spent
deliberating which was a little more
than seven hours they also discussed the
decision
to put bahana rivera on the stand
we had a situation where a client gave a
statement
and he had her dna in the trunk
and he led him to the body that's all
pretty
incriminating evidence um
and from the very first day we met mr
bahina the story he
put forth on the stand was exactly the
version of the events he told us
going back to august 2018 he had never
varied from that version of the events
you know i think there was speculation
that we made some sort of you know uh
you know let's let's figure out a story
and
i mean if we were going to make
something up we would have came up with
something better
than that and chad freeze was asked by
one of the reporters whether or not he
and his wife who
they tried to case together ever tried
to find those two masked
men that the hana rivera said kidnapped
him and freeze responded that that would
be kind of like trying to prove that
there's not a santa claus
fahina rivera is in custody being held
without bail
and he will be sentenced on july 15th in
montezuma era
montezuma iowa where this crime occurred
brian
thanks angenet let's bring in co-host
terry austin terry is this the verdict
you expected and does
seven hours of deliberation sound about
right to you
the verdict that i expected and i think
seven hours is the perfect amount of
time
this was overwhelming as far as the
evidence was concerned we had
video of the car there was video of
molly there was blood in the trunk
there's no doubt that there was enough
to convict
and i do believe that he himself
undermined his story
with these two strangers appearing and
literally
disappearing so i think that hurt him
very much when he got on the stand and
said that even if it had been something
he had been saying all along and frankly
seven hours is just about right because
they must have been talking about dalton
perhaps the fact that
he might have been a suspect but that
rebuttal witness was excellent because
it said no he's not a suspect he has
an alibi here now angenette benejo
rivera faces a possibility of life
without parole
do you think you'll get the max or
something lower
oh i think he'll definitely get the max
just based on
what happened in this case this was not
somebody that
he knew um he was convicted of killing a
stranger
and people who do things like that they
they usually don't stop unfortunately
so um i think he will get the max and
even if he is ever paroled he will be
deported to mexico and what did you make
of the no reaction engineer from
christian vanessa rivera when the
verdict was read in
you know it it must not have been a
surprise to him but he also really
hasn't shown much emotion or much
expression throughout this trial even
when he was testifying and talking about
being abducted at knife point and gun
point on the stand we really didn't we
didn't see him reliving that and see
a reaction from him so i i think to just
see
that he's acted the way he has
throughout the entire case is not
surprising
and terry there's going to be an appeal
all defense attorneys are going to put
an appeal in this situation
but do you see any arguments that could
work here i don't i think
judge yates ran a very tight ship he
didn't air
at all as far as i could see and he
omitted the confession that was given
before the miranda rights were read and
so i think that was the right thing to
do
all right so christiane rivera case is
now found guilty sentencing will be
coming up on july 15th
thank you both still ahead on law and
crime daily why actor bill cosby won't
be getting out of prison
anytime soon but first why doomsay
called mom lori valodebel
could be facing more charges for more
deaths the investigation spanning across
state lines
[Music]
next
welcome back the idaho case against
laurie vallo dave bell in the deaths
of her two children is on pause for now
but prosecutors in another state are now
considering murder charges for the
so-called doomsday mom
for another death long story
she's had kind of a break from reality
that's lori valo de bell's fourth
husband
charles valo the two lived in arizona
and were married for 13 years
but in january of 2019 police were
called when lori took
their son jj and her daughter tyler ryan
he just goes nuts
this time i caught him cheating and i
had evidence and i
told him about it and he travels a lot
for business so
i told him about it and told him not to
come home and that his stuff would be
gone and that his car would be gone
police were again called to the home in
july of 2019 but this time
charles valo was dead lori's brother
alex cox
claimed charles came at him with a bat
and alex said he fired in self-defense
and he came at me with the bat again
after he'd already hit me in the head so
i shot him to stop him it seemed like it
was case closed
laurie moved with the kids to idaho and
she married chad dabal
the kids were reported missing in
september 2019 and their remains were
later found buried
on dave bell's property cox died in his
home in december 2019
and his death was ruled due to natural
causes but
in an indictment filed this week in
fremont county idaho
chad lori and alex cox are named as
defendants in the murders of the two
children
the three are also accused of conspiring
to commit the murder of chad's first
wife tammy
just two weeks before chad and laurie
wed according to court records the
couple endorse
and espouse religious beliefs to
encourage and justify the murders
previously documents show investigators
say they believed in an end of the world
doctrine
they apparently thought the children had
been inhabited by zombies
state of idaho versus lori noreen vallo
lori appeared in court on wednesday but
her initial hearing for the murder
charges was continued
a fremont county judge on thursday
deemed lori mentally incompetent
to stand trial delaying her case until a
hearing on the matter is scheduled
does your husband live here no no
in arizona the chandler police
department announced it has submitted
murder charges for lori in the death of
charles valo
the maricopa county attorney's office is
now reviewing the case
and says they do not have a timeline for
when a charging decision
might be made alright let's jump right
in this
when you read this indictment so many
moving pieces here what do you think the
prosecution's theory of the case is
you know they definitely believe that
laurie chad and
alex all work together to plot the
deaths of
jj tyley and tammy so that's the one
thing that they all three were involved
they were texting
or emailing or calling on the phone so
it's
intimate and then that their religious
beliefs
maybe supported their actions because
they believed in fact that
these people had zombie effects and so
they wanted to get rid of that so that's
one of the things i think the indictment
is showing
that these beliefs are what supported
their actions
but i think if you read between the
lines
what the prosecution is going to be
trying to establish in addition to that
is the fact that money might have been a
motive as well because
they are charging them with insurance
fraud and
also with social security fraud now
terry this incompetency issue that's now
popped up a lot of people are asking
about insanity defenses if that's a
possibility
what do you think this incompetency will
play in effect
if there's a trial that comes up well
you know in
idaho there is no insanity defense and
for competency we have to see whether or
not
she is ultimately found competent to
stand trial
and if she is then she will stand trial
she could say she had a mental illness
and that you know she in fact was not
fully aware of what she was doing but
the prosecution will then have to show
that she had the mens rea the intent
to commit this crime and that's very
possible they may very well be able to
do that
real quick terry do you think she'll be
charged for charles vallo's death
i think that they will be charged or she
will be charged for that because i think
the authorities gave that information
so i think it's going to come down the
line all right we'll see how it plays
out thank you
let's check in on some top stories
making headlines in the law and crime
network
including rock legend rod stewart's
court hearing
the british singer and his son are
accused of simple battery in florida
the palm beach police department says
rod stewart and his son
got into an altercation at the breakers
beach resort on new year's eve 2019.
the two reportedly weren't allowed into
a party when sean stewart shoved a
security guard
and the rock star threw a punch
attorneys say they're talking about a
possible plea
but haven't yet reached a deal the judge
set a tentative trial date for september
14th
former nfl player kellen linzo ii is
spending 14 years in prison
for sex crimes law and crime host jesse
weber is breaking down the conviction on
his latest episode of prime crime
hey brian so a few years back one man
was accused of various sex crimes from
rape
to indecent exposure and to the shock of
the world that man
was star nfl tight end kellen winslow ii
and on our show we're going to go
through the accounts of these five
accusers to break down the evidence and
see
did winslow really commit these acts he
like helped me grab my arms
tell us what he actually did on the side
of the car when you're in the passenger
seat well he had me take my pants off
and um
and pulled me on from this
seat and you know started to rape me
winslow's legal journey through this
case was very unpredictable and we
analyzed his major decision at the end
that changed his life forever tune in
to law and crime thanks jesse
coming up on law and crime daily
everything you need to know about the
murder trial of real estate heir
robert durst plus it's no laughing
matter why one disgraced comedian is
denied parole
bill cosby's team reacts to the parole
board's decision next
[Music]
we're back disgrace actor bill cosby is
staying behind bars
after a parole board denies releasing
him from prison for the first time
cosby is currently serving a three to
ten year sentence for drugging and
sexually assaulting a woman in 2004.
the parole board says cosby failed to
develop a release plan
and participate in sex offender programs
a spokesperson for cosby says he
eventually proclaims his innocence and
continues to die all allegations made
against him
he's appealing his case and the
pennsylvania state supreme court has not
yet
issued a ruling attorney gloria allred
represents 33 accusers
and says her clients just want justice
to be done
mr cosby was not mistaken about whether
andrea consented
because look look at the f testimony of
the prior bad act witnesses
if he is drugging on sexually assaulting
other women he knows that if a woman is
incapacitated by alcohol or drugs
she can't consent he's not mistaken
about it
he's doing it so that they can't
backward this is co-host terry austin
terry the parole board said
not making a release plan and a negative
recommendation from the department of
corrections
where reasons cosby was not to be
released could he get another chance to
be released if those things change
he could brian absolutely see he can
only have to
make a release plan that is not that
difficult to do and
he could also go do the treatment
program that can't be that difficult
either so
those two things are pretty easy to
accomplish and i think if he did those
things
that we would see the jail making a
positive recommendation
rather than a negative recommendation
and ultimately
i think if the recommendation comes from
the jail positively
the parole board will ultimately say yes
you can be released on
you know parole so we'll see but it's
possible
yeah and oftentimes people get denied
the first time they go to the parole
board so that's not too
um strange or odd in this situation
terry also the pennsylvania supreme
court has not decided
on whether five prior bad act witnesses
were too much for this trial
how do you think they'll eventually rule
on that issue
you know those oral arguments were very
interesting to watch
they really did the justices give the
prosecution a hard time as far as these
witnesses these prior badac witnesses
were concerned they thought
that it was too far away in time and it
was too different so i think they're
going to rule
in favor here of bill cosby all right
we'll see how that plays out if he gets
a noon trial
if the supreme court comes back and
overturns the trial court's decision
thanks terry when we come back convicted
of murdering his missing wife
one wisconsin man learns his sentence
hear the tearfield please from the
victim's family
ahead
[Music]
welcome back the trial of the
millionaire real estate air accused of
murdering his best friend
is dark this friday but we've got you
covered on everything you need to know
so far robert durst is accused of
shooting susan berman in the head
execution style in december 2000.
prosecutors say berman had information
about the disappearance
of durha's first wife and threatened to
go to the police his defense say he
didn't kill berman
and doesn't know who did durst is
expected to take the stand in his own
defense
be sure to tune in to law and crime
network the only camera in the courtroom
for gavel to gavel coverage
and now to wisconsin where a man will
spend the rest of his life in prison
without the chance of parole for the
murder of his missing wife
james prokopovic was convicted of
first-degree intentional homicide
of victoria prokopovic she disappeared
in april 2013
and after a lengthy investigation james
was arrested in may of 2019.
prosecutors say prokopovich disposed of
his wife's body in a sludge pond
to be with his new girlfriend the
defense focused on victoria's history of
mental illness
saying the missing wife took her own
life at sentencing
victoria's daughter pleaded with the
defendant to help her find her mother's
body
our mom remains missing and we can we
will continue searching
i would even asked that if he were to
tell us where she is
that he if he gave us the answers we
need that you be lenient in your
sentence
the answers will bring my mom back
but they would allow us to grieve and to
heal
and i would hope that with time
we could find find forgiveness and peace
in this tragedy
he does care about his wife
there is a lot that went on over the
last eight years
and he is a very caring individual
and looking at those galleon factors and
say that he he has a terrible character
that that's untrue
but as far as his character goes i can
tell you that
he does love his family he did love his
wife
and he also loved his girlfriend
kathy friday i knew you weren't gonna
today say victoria can be found in this
location at that location
i'm hoping maybe after a while in prison
and it probably won't be a day or a
month or even a year maybe it'll be a
couple years
maybe someday you will decide to give
the answers to the children
and let them know where victoria is so
they can
they can put this to rest or get some
closure terry let's talk about the
sentence and the finality here do you
think this was the right sentence and
do you think it could be overturned on i
don't know appeal do you see any
arguments there
i didn't see any arguments there brian
for appeal you know
in order to get a case reversed like
this you'd have to show that there was
some legal error that
there was evidence that was not properly
admitted or
that it was an incorrect jury
instruction and i just don't see that
here
or you know jury misconduct i mean i
suppose that could still be possible
but we have no indication of that and he
definitely
had good assistance of counsel so i
don't see that there's going to be any
grounds for appeal here
now having said that is this the right
sentence for the crime
and i think it is the right sentence for
the crime i think he's 75 or
plus and i think that you know spending
the rest of his life
in prison is probably the right thing to
do yeah now tara i know we have this
discussion before
if pro capovich did come forward with
information as to where victoria's body
was
do you think that he should be
re-sentenced to a lower charge
i personally don't like doing that but
you could tell that the family would
really like to find out so i think maybe
here yes
all right well thank you terry and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you